welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to the silence has just dropped on
Netflix and this modern horror film with
the twist has a lot to unpack from it
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the movie the inspiration behind
it and its ending I'm gonna try my best
not I mentioned bird box or a quiet
place at all throughout this review and
judge it on its own merit but man it's
gonna be difficult anyway this is of
course going to be filled with full
spoilers on the film so if you don't
want to know anything about the movie
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now without the way I hope you enjoy the
video now let's get into my breakdown of
a quiet bird box to the silo are crap
right that's the last time I swear
anyway the silence is adapted from a
book of the same name by Tim Leben this
2015 release similar to the film follows
Ali who lost her hearing her young age
and has had to adapt to the world around
her to make matters worse the finding of
a cave that as millions of years old is
an earth and from its Springs of wealth
of monsters that prey on sound seeking a
quiet place off off sorry seeking a less
noisy environment the family decide to
travel to Scotland as they're based in
Britain and along the way they run into
people who've devolved into uncivilized
heathens that wish to survive in this
now lawless society this came out way
before all the other similar films and
is technically the original though
overall it doesn't quite capture the
same level of intensity that those
movies had anyway the film follows the
source material quite closely and we
opened with the unearthing of an
uncharted cave in Pennsylvania vicious
pterodactyl spring forth from it and
completely decimate the scientists
that's discovered the area and spring
forth into the world due to the absence
of light within the cave the
pterodactyls or vests as they come to be
known have evolved to the point that
they now hunt using sound and this makes
humans and easy
it these pterodactyls are absolutely
ferocious and will rip the bird right
out of its bird box aw crap
look I'm sorry I didn't mean that one
please don't thumbs down the video
anyway it's here that we join ally who's
similar to the source material lost her
ability to hear a young age through a
car crash that deafened her and killed
some of her grandparents
Ally's father has remarked on her
ability to adapt to the world around her
and the character almost has a sixth
sense of awareness through having to
rely on the rest of his senses I'm kind
of hoping right that they just keep
making these horror movies that deprive
the senses so eventually hopefully we
can get the scent whoever smelt it dealt
it or the silence too silent but violent
back to this movie though there's a real
sense of loss in the family and they're
very overprotective of Ally who we see
the world through the eyes of is it
slowly torn apart by attacks of the
newly discovered creatures through the
use of social media and viral videos the
family quickly discover that the silence
is the only way to survive and they
decide to get as far away from the city
as possible assisters obviously where
the most noises now where this differs
from most other films with a similar
aesthetic is that the silence shows the
attacks from the point of view of random
civilians early on this is scene where a
mother and her crying baby get attacked
on a subway after their house today at
rain by fearful members of the public
and this sets up the notion that most
people are selfish and will do whatever
it takes to survive this is confirmed on
the road when Allie and her family run
into a man who tries to take their car
at gunpoint
but luckily Ally's dad's best friend
Glenn who's such a good guy that
everyone calls him uncle shoots the man
in the leg and they managed to get away
however it's not the first run-in that
they have and it becomes apparent that
humans are pretty much the polar
opposite of the best humans are stupid
listen to Boris Johnson and will kick
their grandmothers out of the car for an
extra like on Facebook whereas the best
move is one cohesive unit and are
therefore far more deadly this kind of
plays into the ending and which humans
have to adapt to survive and we see them
sort of hunting in the same way that
gasps to which I'll focus on later
anyway when going off-road Glenn crashes
his car and becomes wedged in the
vehicle knowing he's a goner and being
such a great guy Glenn says that he's
going to shoot Ali's dad if he doesn't
leave back at the car the dog starts
barking and this draws the attention of
the best Glenn fires his gun to draw
them away and they swarm on him these
little air piranhas quickly rip them
apart and Ally's father puts the family
dog out the car because it won't stop
barking which I got a bit annoyed about
because why didn't you take a muzzle or
something don't kill the dog I mean
there's this dog next door right and
every time I try and record a video it
starts yapping away and even though it
acts like that I still wouldn't kick it
out the car I mean how stupid are you
Ali's dad if you keep feeding animals
they're gonna think there's a food
source in the area have you not seen
jaws anyway due to this the family end
up having to wait it out for a couple of
hours before the father decides to exit
the car unfortunately Ali's grandmother
who's a smoking asthmatic suddenly gets
a coffee and one of the best swarms in
which forces Ali's dad to make a
distraction from this he discovers that
the creatures are blind as a bat and
sets fire to Glenn's car which draws
them in and then explodes clearing most
of the area the group make it to the
farm which is when a crazy old lady with
a gun comes out shouting for them to get
off the land and I guess she must only
watch fox news because she has no idea
what's going on and quickly gets ripped
apart by the best and what's probably
the most unintentionally hilarious
moment of the movie get out go on get up
anyway the group crawled through a
tunnel in order to get to her house
which forces the father to turn on a
wood chipper and it's as badass as the
old woman's death is funny I would
literally just turn that on all day and
sit back and enjoy that mean old lady's
delicious sandwich this video was
brought to you by mean old lady
sandwiches eat wisps anyway as the
family bunker down it's at this point
that we start to learn that religious
nuts have been sacrificing atheists to
vest
as they believe that they have come to
purge mankind due to the mother of the
family being bitten badly by one of the
creatures she gets an infection and Ally
and her father have to head out to get
antibiotics which is when they draw the
attention of the religious people in
case you haven't worked it out already
this film is very anti right and the
religious people can sort be viewed as a
metaphor for right-wing people
attempting to silence free speech
through vests and thus now that they are
the main Authority in the land the
family become their new target the movie
sort of highlights the dangers that come
on one side of the argument manages to
gain complete control and the
antagonists are representative of an
oppressive force that believe they have
the right to do it because they've been
gifted with an apparent higher power
whilst this metaphor works with a lot of
beliefs and governments the silence is a
clear shot at the trauma administration
and some of its policies this political
mind state is seen with the evolution
and adapting comment made at the end by
Ali and it shows that when one side of
the argument gets too powerful the other
one started to diminish which is when
they must fight back anyway before I get
too bogged down in political subtext Ali
and her father went looking for supplies
discover that the bests lay their
offspring in the body of the dead and
leave the shop which is when they run
into a character known as the Reverend
Ali and her father just want to be on
their way but you know what it's like
when you're walking down the street and
a religious guy stops you to tell you
about his flock in the apocalypse and
alia Netaji's end up having to leave
abruptly his flock known as the hushed
have resorted to cutting their tongues
out in order to stay silent and this
shows their dedication to their beliefs
now I know I said I'd stop mentioning
Bird box but in the book sending the
School for the Blind that the characters
eventually reached was originally
actually just a place full of
self-inflicted blind people so it's nice
that in this film we at least get a
version of something that was originally
deemed too dark for the movies the
Reverend follows Ali and her father home
and creepily stands outside looking at
them and smiling he tries to recruit
them once a game but Ali's father
politely requests to be left alone which
is when the Reverend says that why he's
really come for its Ali who is fair tile
needless to say this isn't good news and
they retreat and by that time what I
love about these villains is that
so sinister and calm a lot of the other
films in the genre would probably have
some over anger towards the group but
these are almost pacifists and try to
avoid fighting as much as possible it's
at this point that Ally learns from a
boyfriend robbed of safe zone up north
known as the refuge however in the dead
of night the hushed attacked the farm by
sending in a girl strapped with mobile
phones that all have alarms set on them
which causes the bests to swarm in as if
the iPhone alarm wasn't annoying enough
already
now it's being used to murder people
honestly though this is where the film
really ramps up and I loved seeing the
phones being thrown through windows and
uses weapons
this gives the hush time to sneak in and
attempt to grab Ally which causes the
grandmother to rush them and sacrifice
herself in order to kill some of the
attackers the group flanked the hushed
and managed to kill a majority of them
but you really get the feeling that
there are no winners here and they shot
the best flying above the carnage
solidifies that the overseers still
during the world to me this sort of
represents the people fighting it out
amongst themselves and the government
let it happen as they're still in
control and it doesn't affect them well
then it's shown a montage of the family
making their way up north and Ali is
reunited with Rob from the ending
monologue we get the feeling that this
is really a race to the top of the food
chain so this can be viewed as a race
between progressives and non
progressives in society and the ending
highlights that though there are no
right or wrong rulers of the planet
eventually one will be decided dependent
on few adapts the most factor Ally
easily kills the creature that wonders
of north highlights that it is the
humans that will most likely win though
it becomes clear that the bests have
adapted to the environment and have even
started to lay eggs there there's an
indicator that the survival of the
fittest race may go on forever but we
close on a hopeful ally heading to
tackle the problem head-on overall it's
an ambiguous ending and whilst the movie
is a little underwhelming I did still
have a lot of fun with it
I would love to have seen this as a TV
series as crammed into just 90 minutes
it feels a little underdeveloped this
feels like a first chapter we're down
the road there would be potential for a
lot more still the movie was fun and was
it's getting slayed online I did still
enjoy it overall the silence for me gets
a 6 out of 10
obviously I'd loved hear your thoughts
on the film and
he took anything differently from it
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this breakdown then make sure
you check out my latest video on
everything we know so far about Avengers
and game which will be linked at the end
this is the channel for people who were
made into movies so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]